the day of the bootcamp we have the
pleasure to listen to martin jorginski
um who was uh who had his phd from the
warsaw uh university
and uh who has even been a postdoc in
berkeley
even if you are not there right now
um and who is now an associate professor
in the warwick university
and uh and the machine uh so has been
working
on many subjects like concurrency
infinite
state system and uh and has done a lot
of work on games and in particular
parity games
and i'm sure that we will know a lot
from his wisdom
now please marcin we're listening to you
so many thanks
i just have a little problem i'm hearing
tomah
still talking with a delay of
maybe 30 seconds
do you have us live stream uh on as well
is that me
yeah i'm wondering if you if you're also
viewing the livestream
yes it's uh it's a mess so what's um
can you please help me
maybe you can close all brothers that
are around to start with
yeah i'm wondering if you if you're also
viewing the live stream
yes it's a mess so what
yes please give me a minute
okay i think uh my situation has
improved
can you still hear me hear me well yes
oh great uh many thanks for for helping
with this uh well many many thanks for
for the invitation to the organizers uh
it's it's a
pleasure and a privilege to uh to give
this tutorial
uh i miss berkeley uh i've had a few
very good years there and it would have
been lovely to be there now but hey
um now um
it's a big topic um
and my decision has been to
narrow it down so this tutorial is
fairly focused
and deals mostly with parity games and
maybe a few
applications of parity games luckily
thanks to the pandemic and the unusual
schedule
of this program
the workshop on equilibrium games
is going to start very soon in
about two weeks so we will have a
weekly fix of various other aspects of
games that i decided not to talk about
so apologies if you were
hoping for a much broader spectrum
[Music]
but i hope that you will still find uh
find it insightful and
interesting to take a closer look at uh
party games in particular
uh uh which is the focus of today's uh
uh session uh on the recent advances
in the complexity of solving parity
games
namely various techniques which allowed
to develop quasi-polynomial
bounds for for parity games
so some of you may not have
uh watched the videos pre-recorded
videos where i have introduced party
games
several other types of games and gave
several motivations but
just in case you uh you didn't um
let me very briefly review some
notations before
we dive in and talk about
quasi-polynomial techniques so
what are parody games they are playing
by played by two players
on finite graphs at least in this
uh session today we will mostly uh
focus on finite graphs although at the
end may we we might we may touch on on
infinite graphs as well
uh by two players we typically call them
even and odd or although
there is a long tradition of coming up
with a host of different names eloise
and abella
uh adam and eve uh recently even steven
and audrey uh but i will i will be
boring can call them even
and odd and uh in our graphs
which are the arenas on which those
games are played even will always move
in
uh vertices which are denoted by
um a square or a box whereas
odd will typically move from positions
which are either triangles or pentagons
uh whichever are easier to draw and it's
clear that triangles and pentagons have
phi have an odd number of sides hence
hence they are owned by odd and
square or a box um has
four sides and hence it's uh even who
moves
who who owns such a position and then
players
follow paths in such graphs
forming infinite paths
the owner always picks one of the
outgoing edges and then
the whoever is the owner of the target
vertex moves from there
and what the players want to achieve are
um opposite goals so one of them
wants the highest label so every vertex
has a
labor which is a an integer between 1
and d typically
and the player even wants the highest
label the highest so-called priority
that occurs
infinitely many times to be even
and odd uh wants uh this
uh highest priority that occurs
infinitely many times
uh odd so those are parity games and uh
let me remind you
uh one uh concept that we will
encounter several times today which is
that of a dominion
so a dominion for a player in a party
game
let's say dominion for even or box
is a pair a subset of a set of vertices
so subset u
together with a positional strategy so
what is the position of strategy
position strategy is a strategy
which tells a player uh in each of the
vertices
which this player owns to always
choose one of the outgoing edges so so
the positional strategy
uh behaves in such a way players
that who use positional strategy always
pick the same edge
for for every vertex so a a dominion
is a subset and the strategy here
denoted by those fat
by this fat a green edge from
[Music]
vertex owned by even such that
firstly this set is a trap for the
opponent
so it's a trap for triangle a trap
forward which means that
from no triangle is there any edge that
leaves that set you
and moreover that strategy not only
doesn't
leave you but it is a winning strategy
uh uh inside you for even or for box
okay so a dominion is really a set where
even
uh even rules and odd has no chance to
escape
um and another concept very very uh
uh frequently uh reoccurring concept in
in this tutorial is that of an attractor
decomposition
and it's a very detailed complete
description of winning sets
in in a party game so every parity game
graph
can be divided so that's a positional
deterministic theorem
that was proved in the pre-recorded
views
uh so every such graph can be
partitioned
into two subsets of vertices
one for even and one for odd
and um on the set
for even the set for even is a dominion
and in fact it's the largest dominion
for even
the other set is the largest dominion
for odd
uh players have positional strategies on
those but moreover
we have managed to to identify a very
special substructure which each such
dominion has
namely that it can be partitioned into a
collection of sets
of vertices so it's a partition so so
those sets are disjoint
so there's this set d of this which is
the set of vertices of the
highest even priority for a attractor
decomposition of the largest domain of
even
and then we have an attractor so the set
of
vertices from which even can force
infinite number of steps a move to
uh to uh vertices of this highest
priority in our case six note that these
vertices have
at most priority five and then we have
a collection of layers so to say
where we have a subdominion let's call
it
r1 for even where no 5 occurs
and it may be the case that so
it's not really a dominion i should
actually use the right word for that
it's a snare
so a triangle can escape
from uh that set so the opponent odd can
escape from r1
but in an attractor decomposition they
cannot escape to the right in this
picture they can only escape
up or left so this is uh these
right edges for for odd are disallowed
and then t1 is again an attractor
for even either to r1
which is a snare uh for triangle so it
says
subdominion for even
or to uh to these sets where the highest
even priority
occurs so uh so this is this is a a
picture
uh which uh describes this
partition as a hierarchical structure
where
r1 itself has its own um
uh as has its own attractor
decomposition
which is here denoted by a subtree of
the tree of the
tractor decomposition uh denoted and uh
higher up so similar structure occurs a
similar structure exists for for the
opponent as we are going to see these
structures really
help us understand uh uh how parity
games are worn and lost and also
compute compute winning strategies and
and winning sets
so uh today's uh session uh will be
split into
three parts i may go through
all of them i may run out of time it
should not be
a big problem but firstly i'd like to
discuss this um modern understanding of
how we can solve party games using
universal trees
and how that leads to uh
this breakthrough result from caluda
jane who sign of lee and stefan
about three or four years ago that uh
that gave the first
quasi-polynomial algorithm for solving
uh parity games so
this combinatorial structure of
universal trees uh really plays a
fundamental role here and we are going
to
uh to look at various kinds of universal
trees and various kinds of algorithms
that
that can use them uh then in the
next part i'd like to discuss um a
refinement
of this understanding based on on
universal trees and attractor
decomposition
uh where um coincidence between
so-called register numbers and strata
numbers
is is established and then if there is
time uh
i'd like to discuss a couple of
applications uh of universal trees
uh to uh to uh computing nested fixed
points
of monotone functions in complete
lattices
and translation simplifications
of alternating automata onwards
so let's let's start with
what i called pruned magnoljalonka
algorithm
and how it can use universal trees to
solve
uh parity games so we have seen the
magnolia gelank algorithm
in the pre-recorded videos and
um it involved this construction where
the basic
step the basic um
[Music]
unit computation of the algorithm
consisted of of
computing uh two attractors so this
attractor
and that attractor and in between
solving a uh sub game
here gi prime this blue sub game
uh using a recursive call of the
algorithm so
what you can you can visualize all the
recursive calls that
mach not angelonka algorithm does by
sort of considering the top level
recursive call
which then makes a collection of
recursive calls to games with one less
priority so so in this case
uh these are the light blue uh light
blue games
so i will not uh fully explain this this
picture
uh this was discussed in in
at length and very slowly in the
pre-recorded videos
but um that's how we can that's how we
can
uh understand uh that's one way to
understand this recursive
uh algorithm of magneton in gelanka
so this tree can be thought
of as the tree of all recursive calls of
that algorithm where
the recursive calls are
spread across layers where each layer
corresponds to
the to all the sub games that are being
solved
which have successively fewer and fewer
priorities and as we've we've
as i as i've mentioned uh uh
unfortunately there are examples
uh of parity games on which the
magnolialonka
algorithm requires exponential time so
this tree of recursive call
because of magnolialong algorithm can be
of exponential size in particular it's
exponential in the number of
of distinct priorities so here is uh
an ingenious idea of of pavopotis
which is to
simply prune that tree of
recursive calls in a clever but rather
brutal way
so instead of considering um
[Music]
the tree that the algorithm has stated
in the pre-recorded videos
as originally uh stated uh will
construct by considering all this
sub-games that it needs to needs to
solve by the logic of the algorithm
it simply um decides to sometimes
abandon the effort so here imagine we
have made
k recursive calls in which we have
identified a collection of
dominia for the opponent of our
favorite player even so they are
dominion for for player odd
and imagine that our 3t on which we have
decided to
uh to run this pruned tree
uh uh on which we have decided to run
back not angelo algorithm
has only uh k children at the root so
what will the
new pruned algorithm do well it will
simply
declare everything else even if maybe
the next recursive call would again find
a dominion for
odd it just declares it for even
so the first case slices returned by the
first k recursive calls
are allocated to odd uh odd can have
them
and everything else is allocated to even
so you know this is obviously wrong
because there may be games where where
after uh making only k recursive calls
we still haven't ex uh exhausted the
the whole the largest dominion for
for odd and then the answer that the
algorithm will give
will simply be incorrect so so what
gives
um well paris has managed to show
the following fact that for every n
where n typically uh in in this tutorial
denotes
the number of vertices in a parity game
for every end there is a tree which is
of quasi-polynomial size
note that for the original algorithm it
could be exponential
but this tree the paris tree is is of
quasi-polynomial size
of size n power big o of log n
such that if we run the pruned
magnolonka algorithm
on this tree then it will correctly
solve every parity game of size at most
then
okay so that's that's paris's theorem so
let's let's try to see now
why this is true
uh how how can we indeed come up with
uh with such a only quasipolynomial tree
and why the resulting algorithm will
actually be correct despite our
observation that that it obviously does
wrong things sometimes if the trees are
too small
so so let me first explain what ordered
trees are
so as you can imagine
[Music]
well i i didn't make it very clear here
but
uh we will always right so in order tree
in an ordered tree all the children are
ordered all the children of every node
are ordered
and in the pictures here they were
orbits from ordered from left to right
moreover we will as is a
common uh assume that
ancestors are smaller than descendants
okay so so that results
in an ordering a linear ordering of
all uh all vertices all nodes uh in a
tree so it's
essentially the pre-ordering pre-order
ordering determined by the pre-order
traversal of the tree so here we have
two examples of
ordered trees now i will explain the
concept of an embedding of a tree it's
very simple
it's simply an injection of the set of
vertices
of the first tree into the second tree
which preserves the order
okay so this tree on the left embeds
into the tree on the right because we
can see there is this copy green copy of
the tree on the left
which preserves the order and its
injective uh however
if we just flip the order of the
let me see the third and
fourth child in the right hand side tree
then the tree on the left will not embed
into that right hand side tree anymore
because the first
child must be mapped onto the last child
here
because all the first three children
don't have enough
children themselves and then there is
nothing we can map
the last child onto okay
finally let me introduce this slightly
bizarre concept of an interleaving of
ordered trees but it's a very
natural concept in in the context of the
magnelon algorithm
so we take two uh order trees the blue
one and the green one say
and then we interleave them in the
following sense so so we
form a tree whose height is going to be
the sum of heights of the
two trees and uh we are going to
uh make the set of nodes of the new tree
to be
a subset of the product of the sets of
nodes of the
of the two input trees and
uh the way uh this tree is going to to
be constructed is that
uh at every level we have a pair
a node from the first tree and the node
from the second tree
as well as an indication which tree
which of the two trees
is now uh dictating the branching so so
so in this node it's the left the blue
tree that
dictates the branching so we branch from
a
to both b and c from a to both b and c
and we simply copy the other tree the
other tree
uh is currently not involved in
branching but in the next level
it will be the other tree that is
involved in branching and we keep
keep flipping the the rolls of of the
two trees so
it is straightforward to show that this
this interleaving
uh tree uh is is going to be of size
which is at most the product of the
sizes of the
of the two trees so here is the
remarkable
um uh fact uh which
is kind of the the key uh result in
paris's uh in the paris is uh
proof that
[Music]
this the pruned magnoton geelong
algorithm
on a sufficiently large tree
will be correct even if that tree is not
uh of exponential size uh
so so in fact uh paris doesn't state
uh this fact in this way uh this was
then this was going to feather
elaborated
later on but here is here is here's the
theorem
so imagine that we take two trees
let's call them t even antiod and then
take their interleaving
and run magnus the pruned magnolonka
algorithm on it
so so it's right so the prune the this
uh
interleaving operation simply says that
at all
all even levels in magnolic algorithm
it will be tree even that dictates the
branching and at
all odd levels it will be the t audit
tree that dictates
uh dictates the branching and now
imagine that this algorithm
is is run on on this interleaved tree
and return some sets so one set of
vertices is declared for even the other
set
of vertices declared for odds so here we
have this result so it's a partition
it's always a partition that's how the
pruned banknote lock algorithm works
now is this partition correct uh what
about dominion where did dominion lie
are dominia
uh for even uh really in in you
even uh and dominion for od and you odd
under what conditions so here is the
very precise condition which
which uh tells us when a dominion for
even
is going to be on the right side
declared correctly
by uh by this algorithm so the condition
is exactly this
if that dominion has an attractor
decomposition
whose tree embeds into t
even we're talking about a dominion for
even
then this dominion is on the right side
it's completely included in the set
declared by the algorithm for even and
symmetrically if we take an odd dominion
if it has some attractor decomposition
whose tree
embeds into the odd then that's
sufficient for this whole dominion to be
declared correctly
put on the right side of the of the
divide by
um by the algorithm okay
so so so that's a very precise statement
about
uh about which dominion will be
correctly identified by this algorithm
uh
there is a structural lemma that is
needed maybe i'll i'll skip that
but then uh what is really critical for
using this structural results to prove
the correctness of
paris's algorithm is the concept of
tree universality okay because
the tree that paris has constructed will
simply be big enough
to embed all possible trees
which have at most at least and are of
height d half
so they so in other words they will be
nd half
universal and uh and that will guarantee
that the largest dominion of even will
be on the right side because the largest
that we've seen the largest dominion of
even has a
attractor decomposition whose number of
leaves is at most n and height is
d half and likewise for rod okay so so
here we have this
the definition of of the concept of of
uh
what it means for a tree to be nh
universal
so a tree u is nh universal
if it embeds every tree t
which has at most and leaves and is of
height at most h so for example
this tree that we have seen earlier is
for too
universal because if i didn't make a
mistake
these are all
ordered trees
which have at most four leaves or have
exactly four leaves
and are um of a height
uh two and all of these trees embed
into this one okay so uh
what are the the trees that paris has
proposed to run magnolot angelonca
um algorithm uh on the pruned magnolon
algorithm on
well have they have the structure where
uh 3p
and h is defined
recursively or inductively it has a root
it has one very special child at
which we hang off a copy of
p n h minus one so p and h is meant to
have height h and it's meant to be
nh universal okay and on
each side on both to the left and to the
right of that special tree
we have a collection of uh and half
trees
with parameters and half and h minus one
and it's very easy to to convince
yourself that this tree
is nh universal and in fact we are going
to see
later on that in a way it's very
wasteful so so so it's so easily
uh nh universal that it's uh really uh
it really can be optimized and and it
doesn't have to be that
that big but uh right so if you just
look at this construction
uh you can write a recurrence for uh
which upper bounds the
the number of leaves in such a tree um
it's a straightforward recurrence where
we simply have one copy of three nh
minus one
and um n copies of the trees and half
h minus one and you know a little bit of
uh
calculation shows that n
big o of log n is indeed a solution of
that recurrence and hence this tree
is is of course a polynomial size okay
so paris's algorithm is simply
to run the pruned magneton zlonka on a
tree which is the interleaving of two
copies
of uh of paris tree
with parameters n and d half right
because because
we know that every uh the attractor
decomposition of
uh largest dominia both for even and
fraud
uh have at most end leaves and are of
high d half and hence they will
embed into those trees and hence those
trees are big enough to
for the dominion separation theorem to
uh to
imply that the partition will be exactly
right
okay so so in summary the
running time of of paris's algorithm
is um well polynomial
that's every recursive call computes two
attractors so that's that's a polynomial
uh
factor uh times the size of the tree and
that's upper bounded by the square of
the size of power stream
okay so so so this is in fact uh an
upper bound on
on the running time of paris's algorithm
right so um as i told you
um paris's trees are a bit wasteful
so let's see if we can do better
so here is a construction that in fact
precedes
paris which
also yields so again it's an inductive
inductive construction
tree l sub nh which is meant to be
nh universal is defined again to have
this
pivot element so the the special child
where we allow to
um right so we we want this to be
n h minus one universal
and then we on both to the left and to
the right
but somewhat differently to paris but by
not by attaching it to children of the
root but just by attaching
those trees to the roots we we take uh
copies of
l and half h and now it's
it's not too difficult to to show that
this tree is also
uh nh universal by induction on the on
the cons
on the structure of this tree because
right every tree that has at most and
leaves
will have um a child
such that all the children to the left
of it
have at most in total at most end leaves
and all the children to the right of it
will have in total together at most and
half leaves
and then we have that child in the
middle whose number of leaves
we cannot upper bound so therefore we
allow ourselves
um uh up to um and leaves in the middle
but we know that the two halves although
they are trees of height
h not h minus one they have the number
of leaves are bounded by a half so so so
if we assume by by induction that uh
these trees are and half h universal
both the one on the left and on the
right
uh as well as this is an h minus one
universal then then every
tree can be indeed embedded into it okay
and we can write a
similar recurrence for it uh turns out
that this is the solution
of this recurrence and that is actually
significantly better because rather than
uh
being exponential in logarithm of
n now we we can afford a more refined
analysis where
where the where the size of this tree at
least for
large parameters values of parameter h
relative to to to n
is logarithmic in h rather than
logarithmic in n
and that that has that will have uh
applications to party games because in
party games the parameter d
with the number of distinct priorities
is often significantly smaller than the
number of
number of vertices now also uh notably
uh this number the size of such a tree
is in fact polynomial
if if the parameter h is a
sympathetically at most logarithmic
in the number of n
so uh palace's algorithm was
was um followed up um
quite quickly by an algorithm proposed
by lectin and trevor and voicetrack
which followed
paris's scheme uh very closely
but as it has later later on turned out
what it in fact does is to replace
paris's
universal trees by these universal trees
l and d half okay
and the analysis of the algor of the
correctness of the algorithm goes
exactly in the same way it follows from
the dominion
separation theorem uh and the running
time
is now better because it's because it
uses those
uh universal trees that are smaller
and also notably uh
thanks to the fact that these trees
are of only polynomial size
if the uh parameter h
is at most logarithmic it follows
that uh that this
is in fact this so the lactating and
schevjack algorithm is in fact
fixed parameter tractable with respect
to parameter d the number of distinct
priorities
okay so um
it looks like we have made progress
we've we've
improved the complexity by designing
cleverer smaller
universal trees so let's uh let's go on
with this and
design even better trees however it
turns out that
this is almost as good as good as it
gets so
so visual curve has shown that
in fact every nh universal tree
is larger than this quantity which
differs from that upper bound from trees
l and h by maybe a quadratic factor at
most
okay so so these trees l are really as
good as they get
and you can sort of convince yourself uh
that that these two bounds or get an
intuition why these two bounds are so
close by
looking up the corresponding recurrences
for the
upper bound and for the lower bound and
they look very similar they only differ
by this factor of two which in fact
contributes only a linear
uh factor to to the solution
right so so it looks like we hit a we
hit a
hard bound it's uh we can't really
exploit this method any further because
we can't design
even smaller universal trees
so um so far we haven't really talked
about the first
the original quasi-polynomial time
algorithm for
solving party games so maybe that's
where the hope is
maybe we should really understand better
that algorithm
due to kaluda jain whose sign of lien
stefan which is not
related to
ordered trees or universal trees it
seems in fact what
at least you know how how kaludasal have
have phrased their
their the result was that party games
can be solved using
an alternating turing machine with space
which is a product of logan and log d
so now if you if you uh simulate this
this the steering machine uh in time to
power that you will get exactly the
quasi-polynomial complexity
that they have claimed but now anybody
who read that paper
who is from this community where you
know people
learn automata at school uh immediately
saw
that this construction that kalooda jain
who sign of liang stefan has
have given was indeed of an automaton it
was an automaton that was reading
sequences of priorities and
somehow being able and they can be
infinite sequences of such priorities
and somehow that automaton was
was capable of deciding
you know could be used to to determine
the winner
so how how was that done and you know
many people
thought about this and in fact um uh
kaluda
at all themselves were inspired quite
strongly i think and they they mentioned
that by a paper by berner jeannette
valukivic
which is already quite old in which
they also had this automata theoretic
method which allowed
to achieve an algorithm which was which
had the best complexity back then it was
exponential but
but but better than magnelonka
so um
i think it is it i like the the most uh
the explanation that was provided uh by
qualcomm ben fijalgov
uh although uh a very crucial
observation was made by byanchik and
trevinsky
and that is of understanding what
property such an automaton on infinite
words needs to have to be usable
uh to uh get this amazing
algorithmic uh result and uh qualcomp
and visualgov
call it good for uh and these small
games
automaton so so that's that's what this
automaton that uh
kalu data have produced is and i will
try to explain what that means
for an automaton to be good for
anti-small games
so we have discussed good for games
automata and in the pre-recorded videos
and we have seen that
what they allow is to
solve a game with possibly a difficult
winning condition parity is
quite challenging by
taking a product of that game with some
automaton
which has a simpler acceptance condition
which can be used as a winning condition
in the
resulting product game and
if the two games have same winners
then we can solve the difficult game the
complex game using the simpler game
which has maybe some state space blow up
because
we take the product with the automaton
okay so if we take the space state space
blow up
which is quasi polynomial uh by taking
this
uh this uh automaton
uh produced designed by kalu data
we get a quasi-polynomial game which has
safety or reachability conditions and
and that's that's how we can
we can understand uh the solution of
call the
color data but what is this what is this
condition on such an automaton that
guarantees
that such a reduction from
a game to from a complex game to a
simpler game
is correct so so before we can do that
let's uh let's define some languages
of priority sequences okay so so they
are right because this automaton is
supposed to read
priorities that occur in infinite place
and then decide whether
uh this is a winning
play for even or a a winning play for
odd and indeed you know
we can define lim soup even and lim
support
as exactly the set of infinite sequences
where even wins and where audwids and
obviously this forms a partition of the
set of all infinite
infinite sequences but what is more
interesting for application to
to to finite games is to consider their
subsets and i call them here
even cycles and odd cycles with
parameters
and and d right so they are words
of sequences of numbers numbers between
one and d so they have sequences of
of priorities but they uh
are sequences that can only arise
as paths only arise
as parts in a graph
that has at most n vertices uses at
mostly priorities
and in which all cycles are even so what
is this about well
these are exactly the graphs of
positional
winning strategies for even in any games
that have at most end vertices okay so
that's that's how we define the seque
the the set of words even cycles so they
are
words they're infinite paths that that
can only be
formed by following paths in a in a
strategy subgraph of size at most n
and likewise for for odd now we will say
that
a finite safety automaton where safety
automaton essentially
always accepts or maybe only rejects if
it gets stuck
okay so a safety automaton
is an nd separator
if if it is the case that the language
it
recognizes and here it is denoted by
this blue shaded area
separates the set even cycles from the
set odd cycles
so in other words it accepts all
plays that arise from positional winning
strategies
for even in games of size up to n but it
rejects
all plays that occur as winning plays
of positional winning strategies uh for
odd
in games of size at most
okay in fact it is useful to to as
you're
soon going to see to to consider a
slightly stronger notion so
we will say that an automaton safety on
hobbiton is a strong
nd separator if the language
it recognizes in fact separates even
cycles
nd from all
plays that are winning by odd not just
in games of size at most then
okay so this is a concept of a strong
nd separator and here is the separation
method
which arguably uh according to these
you know more newer interpretations of
kalu data
is what's what really happens uh in in
this breakthrough result of cloud as
well
so what they provide is a construction
of an nd separator
and and now any nd separator
if you take its product with a game that
has at most and vertices and at mostly
priorities
then uh this game will have the same
winners as the original party game
okay we've we've discussed we've
discussed why so so that's that's the
the breakthrough result of callu dietal
they produce
in fact what they do is they produce a
strong nd separator
and it's of quasi-polynomial size and in
fact you know they they've done
something quite remarkable because
there are several quasi-polynomial time
algorithms of various
shapes and sizes that were produced
afterwards
but really none of them has done as well
in terms of
of running time if you if you analyze
their their
construction precisely
uh so so uh right that's
that's that's what they have achieved uh
so now we have these two methods we have
the separation method
uh as as um implemented by kahlua desal
and we have this method
based on universal trees so how do they
compare
so what i would like to now to to argue
is that in fact they are not that
different
so firstly let me point out that
if we start from an universal tree
suitable universal tree
okay so if we want to solve games with n
vertices and d
priorities uh as we have seen what we
need to take is an and the half
universal tree
so the leaves of every anti-half
universal trees
can be turned into can be given some
structure
which will indeed be a strong nd
separator okay so from universal trees
we can
produce strong than the separators and
separate nd separators can be used
using the separation method to solve
and these small games or games with at
most and vertices and
and the priorities how can we do this
well the construction is actually quite
quite uh quite simple right so imagine
we have a universal tree
in this case i think it's uh it's i
don't know
uh two maybe four
uh four um two universal
doesn't matter so what i prom what i'm
promising is that we will take
as states of our safety automaton
the leaves of such a tree and here's the
construction
right so because this automaton needs to
read the letters which are priorities
and in this case i'm considering four
priorities
because i'm considering a tree of height
two
[Music]
i need to only tell you what are the
edges
for priority
one for priority two for priority three
and
for priority four so these are all the
letters in the alphabet of such an
automaton
okay so for priority one or for letter
one
we are simply going to uh uh make this
introduce these these transitions which
move to the next
to the next leaf next in the ordering
for uh letter three we are going to
introduce edges which
move from a leaf to the
first leaf so for example from this leaf
to the first leaf in the next sub-tree
at level three so level three is here
okay so from this leaf we will have an
edge to this leaf because
this is the current level three sub tree
and we are moving to the next one
uh so that's what we do for all uh odd
letters odd um priorities
okay we move to the net to the first
leaf the smallest leaf and the next
subtree of the corresponding level now
for even priorities what we are going to
do is that we will
instead move back to the first leaf
in the subtree at the current level so
if we see 4 because this is level 4 in
our tree
the top level from every leaf we are
going to
move back to the first leaf in the level
4 subtree so it's the first leaf in the
whole tree
but if we consider level two then we
move to the first leaf
at a level two subtree to which
the currently belongs to okay so this is
the construction
and it's actually quite
easy to see that uh right so what do we
need to do now we need to prove that
uh an automaton constructed in this way
okay and then if we kind of okay so so
what i didn't say is
is that we have this rejecting state so
i said that we can either get
a reject in a safety automaton by
getting stuck
or by and that's what i prefer to do
here
by sort of moving to a rejecting state
from which
nothing can happen okay so so what we
what we
uh so so so in those automata that i'm
constructing here
we reject when we uh
uh get an odd priority
from for which there is no next uh leaf
so if we
if we move from the last leaf uh uh if
if we
encounter not priority at the last leave
then then we immediately reject
so it's actually easy to see that uh
this automaton will reject
all uh sequences of priorities that are
losing
for even or that are winning for odd
okay and that's because
some odd priority uh that
okay so let's take that priority that
occurs uh
highest odd priority that occurs
infinity many times
right after some some of its occurrences
no higher priorities will occur anymore
and then
from then on each time we consider when
you encounter this odd priority
we pre we increase uh the leaf
and the tree right so we cannot we
cannot uh
uh we cannot go back and therefore
eventually we'll fall out of the tree
now the proof that the automaton instead
accepts all words that are produced by
by
graphs in which of small size of size at
most n
in which all cycles are all cycles are
good
even is a bit more technical uh
so so so it's omitted here but it
follows from the existence of
a variant of attractor decompositions
okay
so on small even graphs we have
attractor decompositions
they have small trees and and
because because these trees are small
they embed into the
universal tree and hence and hence we
can argue that the automaton will
will accept okay so uh so what we have
shown is that from every universal tree
we can produce
a strong separator with corresponding
parameters but
what is also possible to to to prove is
um and you know there are two proofs and
one is maybe more elegant than
than another so so i will let you pick
which one uh you would like to look up
if you're interested in that
so so so there's also
a result which says that if you take any
strong nd separator then
necessarily inside that state space
you must be able to find a universal
tree as well
okay so so those two results show that
essentially universal trees and
separating automata
uh are um in some sense equivalent or at
least the sizes
smallest sizes of such separating
automata and of uh
of suitable universal trees coincide and
hence
both methods the method for solving
party games using
universal trees and the methods using
separating automata
are equally bad and hence the lower
bounds for
the size of universal trees also apply
to
separating thomas and hence we cannot
hope to
to find algorithms for parity games
that uh construct uh
separating automata that are even
smaller than the ones we've we've
obtained for example from universal
trees
okay so uh so that
um is um kind of
some uh sobering news which
which you know shows that that we've run
out of
out of techniques uh universal trees
separating automata they all
um face this barrier uh which is
the lower bound on the size the
quasipolynomial lower bound
on the size of universal trees
so finally maybe before a short break
let me let me quickly tell you about
another algorithm which is in fact
uh not not uh
uh not entirely new uh it's uh
it's been known uh in as
a as a slightly different variant called
the progress progress measure lifting
uh for for quite a while but that can
also be
made to work on universal trees and um
that has several advantages over the
previous method so
so what what one could uh say as a
critique
of the pruned magnolonka as for example
implemented by paris or
latin and cheva and voidchuck
or about the separation method
well so firstly the pruned magnolonka
has complexity which is uh quadratic in
the size of the universal tree
okay so the
separation method actually was better
because
uh it was only linear in the size of
universal tree because somehow
the approach is to focus only on one of
the two players and that
allows to reduce the complexity from
quadratic in the size of the universal
tree to linear
in the size of the universal tree and
that matters because these universal
trees are significantly larger
than the games themselves
[Music]
a drawback of the separation method is
that at least if you
take it if you interpret it literally it
requires construction
of this gigantic product game
so it has a really high space complexity
and makes it completely unusable
okay of course there may be ways of
avoiding this space and there are ways
of
avoiding this gigantic uh space
complexity and you know this
what i'm going to show you now is is uh
is one way of doing that um but there is
another problem with pruned magnolonka
which we will discuss in the second half
more
namely that in order
right so there's this key result this
dominion separation
results which says which dominion are
on which side of the divide produced by
uh by the pruned magnolia algorithm
and unfortunately if we use trees that
are smaller that are not universal
even if they may be in fact sufficient
to give us
the correct answer right because all the
dominion separation requires is that
uh the trees of our dominion embed into
those trees that are giving us as an
input to the algorithm
we may not be sure because
whether this partition has anything to
do with with the partition between the
winning set of one player and the other
and moreover the printmak not on july
algorithm doesn't produce
strategies so it doesn't produce
witnesses of being correct
right so ideally it should if it if it
can be wrong
it should at least be able to say where
it is where it is right
but unfortunately as stated it doesn't
do that okay so
uh so so this algorithm that i'm going
to present the attractor decomposition
the attractor uh the composition lifting
algorithm
uh corrects that so so it's it's
hopefully going to be more
usable in practice because it can be run
on small trees and if
we are lucky enough that in the game
there are dominion
which embed into those small trees then
these dominions will
then these the dominia will be uh will
be detected
and can be removed and and we can
proceed with the rest of the game
so uh what is an attractor decomposition
uh
labeling so so it's kind of a slight
reformulation
of of the attractor decomposition tree
right so
so we are going to view it as a a
function
which maps vertices uh in the game graph
onto nodes in some order tree
now because in the attractor
decompositions
we had two types of nodes the green
nodes and the red nodes
and the green nodes were good
nodes right they only had vertices of
high
even priority and the red nodes were bad
nodes because
they had vertices of potentially high
odd priorities that
we wanted to leave eventually
[Music]
we will we will introduce these rules
which say that
if a label of a vertex is green
then it must necessarily be the case
that
the level at which this
node onto which vertex v is mapped
onto is in fact equal to the priority of
that vertex
recall the levels were assigned in the
top-down
fashion right uh it was a bit
counterintuitive because uh because the
top level
uh because children of of a node of a
certain level have two different two
distinct levels
right because the red notes have
uh have level that is one higher than
the green
notes each note each green note has both
green children and red children
and the red ones are bad the green ones
are good
and and they are allocated to odd and
even levels now if a label of a vertex
happens to be a red node
then uh then the priority of that vertex
is either equal or smaller to
the level of that node okay so for
example here only
vertices of priority six are mapped
on this green node only vertices of
priority four are mapped
but on this red nodes we can have
vertices
priority five or or smaller because they
contain attractors
uh and then we will say that um
um a um
a vertex a vertex
in such a labeling is progressive
if even can reach um
vertices whose labels are either
strictly smaller
or are in the subtree okay and likewise
if the label of which is
a label is a node in the tree of a
vertex
is red then even can in one step
uh or maybe in more steps there are two
variants here and that's the difference
between progress measures and attractor
decompositions avoid the vertices
whose labels are strictly larger than
this no node l
and eventually reach
vertices whose labels are strictly
smaller
and you know this may look complicated
but it is nothing
but a formalization
of this picture we've seen earlier about
attractor decompositions where even has
strategies to move out of
attractors and make progress odd cannot
move right and eventually we hit
either we get stuck in one of the
sub-trees or we move
up and see a high
even priority okay and
once we absorb this slightly technical
definition
the algorithm that i'd like to now
suggest is is actually quite simple
because what we do
is first observe that um a smallest
such a labeling exists
okay so so
in fact if you take two such labelings
then
right there are labeling into nodes in
an ordered tree
so you can take a pointwise minimum of
two such labelings
and you can you can simply take label
vertex
with the smaller of the two labels given
by two labelings
and that minimum is always going to be a
correct
such uh labeling okay so
so therefore if you take the minimum of
all such label links it will give you
the smallest one
so the algorithm uh is very
straightforward
first you assign a label to every vertex
which is the smallest possible label in
the tree right the tree is ordered so
there's always the smallest one which
will satisfy these
these level consistency conditions
and then it may be that perhaps
some of those labels do not satisfy
those progressiveness conditions
well then if you find such a vertex
which does not which is not progressive
which does not satisfy the
progressiveness conditions
you can minimally lift it so as to make
it progressive
okay and if you continue doing that what
will
what will be the case throughout it will
be an invariant that you will always
the current labeling will always be
below that smallest labeling that exists
which is simply the
the minimum of all the correct labelings
okay so eventually you will actually
compute it
and and the nice fact about about this
algorithm is that once you have computed
the smallest labeling
and if you've used 3t
okay so you are labeling vertices using
some ordered treaty
large small universal not necessarily as
long
as some dominion d
embeds into the stream in the sense that
it has some attractive decomposition
which embeds into this tree then
the result that should be a mu t star in
fact
then uh then the resulting labeling that
the algorithm will compute will uh
correctly identify this dominion as uh
as winning enable it will have a correct
label
and this algorithm is is fast compared
to
pruned magnolonka because it is linear
in the size of the tree
and moreover for these constructions
these recursive constructions of
universal trees that we have seen
you know that like the tree l sub nd
for example uh you can you can in fact
uh very efficiently perform these
operations of lifting
uh labels in a tree uh
and and it only takes a space which is
uh virtually
uh virtually linear in the size of the
graph okay so so
so this family of algorithms is likely
to be uh to be quite
quite efficient uh now i would like to
maybe state um what i call the small
three thesis so it's not a conjecture
because it cannot be
proved but it can be tested
and it should be tested empirically so
so so here is my
my call for uh a program of empirical
uh research uh on party game solvers
and various party games that occur in
the wild and we have some
some really nice large sets of
benchmarks
and my thesis is is that in the wild
many large games that you know occur
either organically
or synthetically i will discuss those
uh in some more detail later uh they
should have uh attracted the
compositions whose trees are relatively
much smaller than the size of sizes of
those games
now having an algorithm which will
produce a witness
a strategy uh even if for
possibly large dominion even if the game
is gigantic and tree is small as long
as a dominion has a small decomposition
uh
um you know could could be valuable
so so you know in practice i i suggest
that
such an algorithm and we are going to
see some refinements of that
based on families of so-called stroller
universal trees
could could be quite quite effective
maybe even efficient
um and the idea here would be to do this
you know what people an algorithm
call a doubling trick you first start
with some
reasonable guess of a tree that may be
sufficient
and if it is not double its size if you
have a
suitable family which allows you to pick
intelligently
trees that are likely to eventually find
the right structure of an
attractor decomposition which is
sufficient
then the resulting algorithm will
actually be
linear in the size of the final tree
that
that that is
is sufficient okay so um
toma do you think it's a good idea to
take a five minute break
yes it's a good idea to take a five
minute break so let's take five minutes
thank you
hello again hello martin
uh let me just uh ask if there are any
questions
any questions
yeah maybe a question about
you you have said that you need large
memory for this
aftermath approach right
right but can't you
yeah i mean it seems
well if you know can you like
locally treat this automotive so to
specify
state of it if there are
quasi-polynomially
many states you need polylog beats and
you probably need some
in your memory to memorize your game
so as we have seen the
automata and the trees
are very similar they
have the same underlying structure or
very similar underlying structures
so so you could argue that the the
algorithm i have presented at the end
that maintains some
labelings of vertices in the graph
by nodes in the tree which are
succinctly represented is indeed doing
that and
and uh
not fish alcohol and uh and co-authors
uh have indeed um
[Music]
considered such a analogous algorithms
which work not on trees
but on what they call universal graphs
which are very closely related
to those automata and what what
the reason one reason why why they did
that
is that those techniques work not only
for party games but also for other
games
sasha did that address
your question
uh yeah i guess so i think thanks
all right if there are no other
questions
then let me move on to the second part
of today's session
where i would like to discuss a concept
introduced by
carolina lehtinen who
has contributed yet another view on why
party games can be solved in
quasi-polynomial time a year after
kaluda tiles breakthrough
and that's called a register number
and um what she uh
what she called register games
uh and uh i will argue that this happens
to coincide
with um what we define to be
uh a strala number of a party game
uh and uh these strong numbers uh
keep reoccurring uh in computer science
every now and then
so so so there are some nice stories um
related to those so so hopefully
uh you will enjoy that right but before
i talk about strata numbers
uh let me uh tell you um what karolina
lectinan has
has proposed so
um in the spirit of automata that are
good for small games
um one can indeed
one can indeed say that what's what her
proposal is is to construct
such good for small games automata so
so the construction of this so-called
register automaton
um is um at first a bit paradoxical
in the sense that um its
size is going to be at least the size
of the automaton proposed by uh
kaludatal
so in a way no gain on on
[Music]
performance on on complexity
in a way we shouldn't expect any better
we now
know because uh there are these bounds
based on universal trees
which show that the the automaton of
khalodetal is close to being optimal
moreover in the automaton that
carolina has has introduced this this uh
this register automaton the acceptance
condition
is not as simple it's not
safety but it's in fact again a parity
condition
so what's going on are we now going to
use automata
some complex sophisticated automata
to reduce solving party games to solving
party games so that sounds paradoxical
but what
is remarkable in canolina's approach is
that the number of priorities that
this new product game
would have right the game obtained from
the original game
and the good for small games automaton
um is is going to be reduced to only
at most logarithmic in the number of
vertices in the original game
so it's an interesting interesting
concept and we are going to to
confirm that it is really interesting
and and
uh touches on something fundamental uh
when we establish the
the the coincidence of that regis what
kalina calls the register number
uh with the straw numbers so first let
me tell you what this register automaton
is
so it's it's slightly cumbersome to
describe because
many things are happening but let me let
me briefly
tell you so what are the states of the
register automaton with k
registers so the states are
k tuples of
what she goes calls registers
and each register simply holds one of
the priorities
right so they are k tuples of values
between one and d
where d is the highest priority um
now what the automotive the automotive
is going to be non-deterministic
and what are the non-deterministic
moves well whenever the automaton reads
a priority right so a priority is
is a is a number between 1 and d
it can decide to reset any of its
k registers so here i have an example
where where this transition corresponds
to resetting register three
so what does that mean well there are
some a number of steps here
a bit of bookkeeping so let's let's do
it step by step
so firstly what happens that when the
automaton resets when the transition
resets
register three what happens is that
registers two and one
by the way we number registers from
right to left so we have register 1
register 2 register 3
4 and 5 in this case so firstly
registers
smaller than 3 so registers 1 and 2 are
reset to zero
okay so the smallest possible priority
let's say
moreover what we do is that we take this
priority which is a letter that we are
reading right the automaton is reading a
letter
and then we are looking at all the
registers
three if we are resetting three and
higher
and if that letter is higher than any of
those
then we replace them by this new
priority so
right so now register three contained uh
priority four
now it's going to contain priority five
because registers
remember right so that's the intention
here registers
store the highest priority seen
since it was last reset
um and then the higher registers
in this case are not modified because uh
five the priority we now read happened
to be
uh smaller equal than the values in
those registers
before so so that explains
how we update registers if we decide to
reset
say register three and we see priority
five
but moreover this is going to be a
parity automaton again
and the
priorities will be now associated not
with states as is
typically done but with transitions
doesn't matter so much in this case
so this is going to be a priority of
that transition
that reset three transition and why is
it seven well it's going to be
two times the register number so two
times three
and then plus one if the priority that
we have seen
is or the priority that is now
in register 3 is odd or
or just nothing plus 0 if that priority
was even
so the number of distinct priorities
that we will allow
is two times the number
of registers right so
if we construct this automaton rk
with k registers then it will be a
parity automaton with two cape distinct
priorities
now what is uh what's what karolina has
proved
and that's the main result in in her
league's 2018 paper
is that if you take register automaton
with log n plus 1 registers
that is good for
games with at most and vertices
okay and from that immediately follows
that party games can be solved in
in quasi-polynomial time because
the size of this automaton is
quasi-polynomial
uh the number of uh priorities is
logarithmic and then even if we use
uh you know an exponential algorithm for
solving this parity game
the resulting complexity will be still
quasi polynomial
it is not as good as the constructions
of kalu de atal
um even not as good as as the
construction of paris
uh perhaps i'm not entirely sure maybe
yeah maybe maybe maybe it's actually
better than paris but but not as good as
kaludata
or the methods based on the the smallest
or nearly smallest
nearly smallest universal trees but it
is insightful nevertheless
and this is this is one reason why
because then
um carolina suggested to to define
a parameter uh for a parity game g
to be its register number so it's the
smallest number
it's the smallest number such that
if you take the product game with
smallest number k such that if you take
the smallest if you take the
product game with register automaton as
define as
as it was just defined with k registers
then that game that resulting game
is is equivalent to the original game
okay and
the observation is that that if you
happen to have
a game whose register number is k and k
is small
that's good because we can solve such
games in time
which is um which is polynomial you know
exponential only in k
it's just exponential in case so so
polynomial say if k was
uh if k was um
[Music]
uh constant and in the paper
and also in the joint paper with with
udi booker where
this result is is is now deposited
in a in a journal uh karina made this
this um bold claim i call it latin and
thesis that in the wild you know games
that appear
in applications or maybe as a result of
some
automata theoretic constructions um
the register number is tiny
and um
and you know we should we should test
this thesis
we should do it so we should do so uh
empirically at the end i will i will
have a few words about some very
preliminary preliminary results
uh but it may very well be that like
lectin and thesis
um um holds uh we shall see
so so you know i was very intrigued by
this parameter
i wanted to understand that better but
also
um you know it's it's natural to see why
it is the case that somehow the
uh worst case which is when latin is not
sorry when when a register number is is
actually log n
the resulting complexity is actually
worse than
than the complexity of um of the best
methods
uh so so that's how we started thinking
about strand numbers
and here's definition of a strata number
of an
offer tree so it's a rooted tree
and the strata number of a rooted tree
this is definition one
is the largest height of a complete
binary tree
that is a minor of our tree so here we
have an example
it's actually a boring example because
we don't take miners at all
in fact the straw number of that tree
is three because there is a
subtree the purple one
which is a complete binary tree and it
has height
three where i divide and define here
height to be the number of vertices
on the longest path from the roots on
the path from the root
uh not of not of edges okay so here's
definition two which is kind of
inductive so a trivial tree has strata
number one
three with just one node or with just
path
um and then if you take a tree which has
a root and
i sub trees then let's look at the
maximum strata number
of each of the sub trees now if that
maximum is unique
then this is also the strong number of
of the whole tree
and if that maximum is not unique so
there are at least two sub trees
at which that maximum is attained then
the resulting stroller number of the
three
of the tree with the roots and these
subtrees is one higher
okay so that's how we get uh that's how
we get
a complete binary tree
so so this is a classic definition in
fact
it has been first studied not in
computer science
it seems but in or mathematics but it
seems it has been studied in hydro
geology
so horton and strahler were
hydrogeologists
who have in 1940s and the 1950s
studied the complexity of river networks
various parameters of how complex the
river networks are
and which of the tributaries are the
main rivers and which are
all that kind of stuff and uh
arguably stroller has nailed the
definitions horton introduced some very
very confused definition strahler has
introduced
what we now call the strata number now
back in 1950s jersey off in
the soviet union has discovered this
number
as the smallest number of registers that
are needed to
evaluate an arithmetic expression
okay so it's a stroller number of the
parse tree of that expression
and then many people have been
rediscovering the strata number in
various contexts
one of those people by far not the first
was javier esparza who in
2014 uh gave an invited talk on the
brief history of
straw numbers and you know there was a
associated paper very enjoyable the
presentation is fantastic as well
you can see the slides on javier
esparza's webpage so i highly recommend
it
and sometime after after the paper was
published
javiera received and co-authors perhaps
received an email
with subject quick note from professor
knuth
in which don kluth writes oh you
probably should be aware that you will
be aware that
strata numbers occur in the art of
computer programming volume 4a
i have learned about the connection to
the work of stroller and
from from xavier viennot
who in 19
published a paper called
trees in a book
uh whose title is the french word for
words
which was in the honor of marcel
berger and it's a fascinating
survey article about all crazy
combinatorics related to stroller
numbers
so you know it's very rich rich topic
there's lots of work i highly recommend
looking up either the art of computer
programming volume 4a
or javier esparza's survey or indeed
xavier viennose survey there's there's
lots
lots to be learned but how do we define
a strand number of a party game
so so here's the definition let's
say that a party game has troll number k
if it is the smallest throttle number of
a tree
of an attractor decomposition of
its largest dominion okay so
strada number measures the branching
complexity of of
trees and now i want to measure
complexity of a parity game
uh by by considering
um you know smallest possible strata
numbers
of trees of attractor decompositions
of winning sets in that game and the
main result
is that straw number is essentially plus
minus 1 equal to the register number
introduced by by lactine okay so
so let me give you a sketch
of the argument why the register number
is smaller equal than strata number
inequality holds
and i will i won't i won't say
much about the other one but right so
what does it
um what is involved in showing that the
register number
is at most something uh well
so if you read carolina's paper
carefully you will note that if
odd wins in the parity game
then they will also win in their
corresponding register game
so it's all about right so in order to
argue that the
the product game is equivalent to the
original game
it's all about showing strategies for um
even using small number of registers
okay so so if you want to to prove so
right so now we want
now i want to argue that
um that if i have an attractor
decomposition of a certain strata number
and here i have a tree
of straddle number three and imagine
that this is a tree of an attractor
decomposition
of the largest dominion in my parity
game
now what i need to show right to in
order to show this inequality what i
need to
show is a strategy for even
in a register game
with three registers right so a game in
which
the automaton that is certifying winning
is using only three registers
um and here's the reset strike right so
so
and note that the automaton uh right
the automation was not deterministic the
register automaton was non-deterministic
so
one source of one one part of the
choices that
even will have to make is of course
which which edges to follow in the game
graph
and that will be simple we will just use
a
positional winning strategy
but what needs to be now
specified is which register should be
reset when
in order for this register system with
its associated priorities
right twice the number of uh registers
to correctly certify uh winning
and um and the reset strategy in this
product game is as follows uh
if your current vertex happens to be
mapped in the attractor decomposition on
a red node
so it's in one of the attractors don't
do anything don't reset
but now in in register games i haven't
said that but in register games you are
not allowed to
to never reset
because let's say if you don't reset
then priority is one so it's always odd
okay so you will lose if you are even in
a party game
so we will never reset in
vertices whose label is a red node but
that's not a problem because we will use
a strategy
right which is a collection of attractor
strategies that always eventually move
out of red node so that's good uh but
then which registers to to reset well
whenever we
land in a green node or in a vertex
whose label is a green node
we are going to reset the register whose
number is the strala number
of the subtree rooted in that node so if
we are in that
node we will reset register 2.
if we are in that node if we are in a
vertex whose label is that node
right so note that these vertices have
priority 4
but which register to reset is not
determined by the level in the tree
but by the strata number of the subtree
rooted in that node
okay so so you know i will not give a
proof but this is
this is the strategy and it turns out
that
um the other inequality almost holds so
plus minus one
and here you know um what is involved
is instead constructing attractor
decompositions from winning strategies
in register games
now register games you know they are
these product games
so they are much larger than the
original game so so somehow finding an
attractor decomposition a small game
based on a winning strategy in a very
large game this is messy business
and and the proof of of this inequality
is is quite technical and
and you know i will not be able to to
say much but remarkably
um this concept introduced by by latinon
which is in terms of this register game
happens to be intimately related to a
measure
of branching complexity of trees of
attractor decompositions
okay so so uh
so to me that fulfills the first uh
motivation and
and sort of challenge um after
having seen uh carolina's work which is
to understand
register numbers i think you know to me
uh that's quite satisfactory that that's
tragic characterization
but uh it turns out that it also helps
tremendously in the second goal of
speeding up the method that
carolina has proposed the method of
solving games perhaps faster
by considering structures of smaller
complexity like this
those those uh register automata with
few registers
right uh so so for that we will we have
we have come up with this
uh construction of small so-called
strala universal trees so what is a
strala universal tree well
we will say that the tree with at most n
leaves and of height h
is a case trailer universal
if it embeds or into it we can embed
every tree with at most inver and leaves
sorry
let me start i will say that this tree
is
nhk strala universal
if it embeds all trees
with at most and leaves of height at
most h and of straddle number at most
game
now note that if a strata number which
is the register number of a game
is at most k then running all the
algorithms we've seen before
on a case trailer nh universal tree
will be sufficient because the trees of
attractor decompositions will embed into
this
case trial universal tree and enhance
the algorithm
the algorithms will give will give
correct answers
and here is the inductive construction
it actually is very similar to the
construction of that
nearly optimal universal tree
which didn't care about strata numbers
except that now we somehow have to
you know have that one subtree where
we have to be able to accommodate the
unique subtree of the same strata number
as we are now considering and
you know everything else will be handled
in a way very similar to the previous
inductive halving
uh halving of the number of leaves on
both sides technique
okay so i will not bore you with
with discussing that in detail and
we are close to to to the end of time
so so let me uh let me just uh
say that these trees are quite small i i
don't have
detailed it seems uh it's i find it
surprising
but yes i don't i don't have detailed
analysis uh
on this set of slides of how large they
are but they're actually quite small
and and in particular they they um
are of a size that is exponential only
in k
but it's even better than that so we
have a kind of new range of
uh new trade-off between strata numbers
um and uh and
how large priorities or heights
are relative to n so how big
h is relative to n which
sort of simultaneously improves both
over
carolina's polynomial time if strata
number is constant
algorithm and kaluda tells a result
that uh if h is
um at most logarithmic then the size is
polynomial in n
so so let me just maybe uh say a couple
of words about experiments
very preliminary experiments right so i
have stated two theses
one was that games in the wild will have
small trees of attractor decompositions
and then maybe a refinement of that
which is
which is partly due to carolina lectin
and which is that
they will have small strata numbers
okay so so we have run some very
preliminary experiments that way
they were masters projects within
students who who left early
and didn't really do a fully rigorous
work but
um but you know we've looked at uh
cairns benchmarks which contain um you
know
well over a thousand games quite large
they are both synthetic so you know like
hard examples for various algorithms or
or suitably picked random
game models but also organ what i call
organic so
you know examples of games that arise
from model checking problems
satisfiability
checking for various model and builder
logics synthesis
competitions equivalence checking you
know
they are games with millions or maybe
even tens of millions of vertices
um sometimes dozens or more
priorities although like model checking
and synthesis
model checking and equivalence checking
examples all have at most four or five
priorities so so
they are not very interesting um
and um the preliminary results are
that indeed we can these trees are small
so even though
you know theoretically if a number of
vertices
in a game graph is in millions we would
need to
set parameter n for the number of leaves
that we have to accommodate in the
universal trees tree to be
to be in the millions it's sufficient to
pick those
in tens or hundreds
and virtually all examples
were solved with a strata number at most
four
so again carolina's hunch that straddle
numbers are tiny
seems to to hold so i think more
experiments
should be should be done um but you know
i've i've seen
that uh that most games
uh in cairns benchmarks could be solved
with
universal trees we've picked hand-picked
the right
well in fact they are they can be picked
automatically uh in an incremental
fashion by using the doubling tricks
um you know they they were solved with
trees that had either tens or hundreds
of leaves
so uh since the complexity of solving
games
is linear in in the polynomial in the
size of the game and then linear in the
size of the tree if
trees are if the the sufficient trees
have
uh sizes in the hundreds then then
perhaps you know that can be turned into
really practical um solution engines for
for party games
okay so um i wanted to mention
other applications of universal trees
for nested computing nested tarsky
konastertarsky fixed points
and for translations of alternating
automata
but i think it's maybe time to stop so
so i will leave it for another occasion
thank you very much thank you very much
martin
do we have questions
questions
yes so uh
please carolina
i don't know i should give you the i
should
okay yes hello oh excellent hello
hello um slightly take
a small technical question about um
strala numbers um
so i haven't seen this deficient
definition of um
if you have a binary tree as a miner
or the what was it the largest uh
binary tree that you have as a minor
high
so that definition i think you can also
use that to define
the strata number the graph by by saying
the same thing
a graph uh looking at the largest
full binary tree that's a minor of a
graph
now if you look is it the case then that
if you take a parity game throw away the
parity game elements and just look at
the graph
that it's on does the australian number
defined in this way
of that graph does that give you an
upper bound
on the australian number of the parity
game
i'm not sure um
the straw number is
is keep in mind that the strong number
is a strong number of um
of an attractor decomposition and now in
an attractor decomposition
i mean firstly um
game graphs are directed
um you could argue that
trees no i'm not sure um
[Music]
it's it's probably yeah i'm not sure
because i guess you're throwing away a
lot of the
like it would well i don't know
my guess would be that it would be of
kind of very large upper bound because
to get a
to get a complicated attracted
decomposition it needs to come from
somewhere but i could be totally wrong
just
but thank you and thank you for the talk
thanks for the question
do we have other questions
hello hello thank you for your very nice
thought
i have a question about your empirical
results oh it's not really
a so you have very small trees have you
looked at the strategies you get
do they have many connected components
or
do they do you have a very big connected
component because it's related to
to dancer
yes um every connected component will
will
um connected components
um so uh let me okay the answer is no we
haven't looked at strategies
so you know we we we have really done
very
very superficial stuff so far we've just
uh
plugged in various uh trees of various
sizes
coming from these families of straw
universal trees and whenever we got a
whenever we got a correct result we
declared success but uh no we haven't
looked at uh structures
for those strategies because what is
your comment about what is your comment
about
uh connected components what did you
want yes so you suppose that in a
winning strategy every component has
less than
100 states
then your almost surely your trees would
be
good enough true
and i don't know but if if games
if uh yeah i mean if if game i see you
say that
uh you you could if if that was the the
only reason for small strata numbers say
then we could have just uh achieved uh
success with the linear algorithm for uh
finding strong negative components
no no no strongly connect components in
this winning strategy not in the game
okay no no it's most apparent
okay okay fine
so i'm just thinking now online i'm not
i haven't thought about this because
before but
your slide kept me thinking
good point it would be it would be it
would be good to you know to look
carefully at those at those uh
strategies
that are returned because if you if you
successfully run
the algorithms on very small trees then
these strategies will have very
simple structure
okay thanks once again yep thanks
okay thank you ego thank you martin um
okay there is still one carolina you are
still raising hand
there is a i can ask the question of
an undergraduate math student
who's looking for references
uh to get the background on this kind of
works what is your favorite book
and what would you suggest for
doing so so there is a participant
uh in this program uh natana nathanael
vishalgov who i understand is preparing
a new book on games
so i i think uh i haven't seen the game
the book yet but
i'm expecting it will be absolutely
splendid so
uh so what i would recommend is to get
in touch with
nathanael okay yes i think the book is
almost over yes
so i will write the name
so that's that's the name of
uh did i send it
yes so please please get in touch with
netanyahu who is who is one of uh
the fellows in this uh in this program
at simons
yes that that's a very good advice um
hey
okay i have a small question on my side
here and it in fact it was exactly on
this slide
you're saying okay k uh well a number of
priorities
is four is boring yes but uh
what what does it mean in terms of
complexity because
all what you've said is for a high
number of priorities but what happens if
you
lower them well
you know when when the number of
priorities
is um is
um let me let me give you an answer in
terms of asymptotics right so
we know that if the number of priorities
is strictly sub-logarithmic
then we have a nearly linear time
algorithm
based just on the standard small small
universal trees
now if the number of priorities
is exactly logarithmic
then we have polynomial time algorithms
but the exponent depends on the constant
and the
logarithmic
but if it's sub-logarithmic then we have
algorithms which are nearly linear
like n power one plus epsilon
so so maybe i can rephrase the question
because the the
uh in this algorithm based on
on small trees are they good in practice
because they try to okay in order to not
pay the price of the worst
case they are averaging everything
so so like without without having tried
that yeah i don't know the answer
but i think that this observation you
know from
those preliminary experiments that the
trees
that are sufficient for gigantic games
have tens or at most hundreds of
leaves i think is very promising and
it's you know definitely
deserves uh more professional
experimentation and
an empirical work so you know it should
be implemented
uh in a professional way and then
rigorous
experiments performed
but i think you know the the the
experiment so far suggests
that there is potential
okay thank you
some last question
okay there does not seem to be any more
questions so
thank you very much marcin for this uh
very interesting uh
talk and very like advanced in this
subject
thank you and yes
bravo
uploading with these systems is always
very complicated
but the heart is there thank you very
much martin
all right thanks see you soon
bye